the aphid one of the most common crop
pests in the world has a weakness that
scientists have now learn to exploit
when attacked by predators
the bugs release a pheromone to tell
fellow insects to scatter biologist -
proposed spraying these alarm pheromones
directly on crops to prevent pest damage
but synthesis is costly with the advent
of genetic engineering though the
cheaper option is to modify crops to
produce the deterrence themselves in
biologists at Rothamsted research an
agricultural research station in the UK
reported the first engineering feat of
this kind in wheat to make wheat release
insect pheromones the group inserted a
gene from the peppermint plant which
allows plants to produce the appropriate
chemical then they tested whether the
altered plants volatile compounds were
capable of repelling the pests using a
multi chambered ol fact ometer to
provide different odor options the
scientists looked at how much time three
types of aphids spent in each
environment all three species spent far
more time away from the areas with the
aroma of the engineered wheat suggesting
the modification successfully acted as a
deterrent
similarly when scientists placed a small
drop of the alarm pheromone made by the
engineered plants on aphid colonies
already feeding on regular wheat most of
the bug dispersed the pheromone has the
added benefit of attracting aphid
enemies such as parasitic wasps and
indeed the researchers found that
compared to controls wast spent more
time hanging around and foraging on the
engineered plants before flying away
finally the team tested the new plants
in the field growing plots of wheat and
Counting the number of aphids and wasps
through several seasons unfortunately
the results observed in the lab were not
repeated in the field the pheromone
releasing plants Harvard populations of
aphids and beneficial insects the same
size as those on regular wheat the
results indicate that while this type of
Engineering is capable of producing
pheromones the ward off pests more work
will be necessary to make sure they
protect crops in real-world conditions
nevertheless once successful the concept
might also be employed to control
insects that's very diseases to farm
animals and people